[Música]
hola soy paulo blikstad es profesora
columbia university en la ciudad de
nueva york que trabajó en el transformar
chiflón in technologies light
estamos eligiendo un tiempo un tiempo
muy difícil para niños de niñas sin
acceso a sus escuelas con terribles
consecuencias con respecto a su
aprendizaje y bienestar
esta vendimia en verdad nos muestra una
realidad que hemos tratado de ignorar a
pesar de la idea que la internet ha
democratizado el conocimiento de la
información esto en realidad no es
cierto
esto es porque la información no es
conocimiento de ver no es aprender
explicar no es lo mismo que enseñar
entonces cuando las escuelas públicas
prometieron dar inicio al aprendizaje en
línea como si fuera fácil mucha mucha
gente pensó bueno esto podría funcionar
si los estudiantes tienen teléfonos
inteligentes de internet podría podrán
acceder a la escuela desde cualquier
lugar
pero la verdad que esto esto no ha
funcionado y porque bueno la educación
es mucho más que tener acceso a
información y vídeos no no se trata de
unas simples transmisión y educadores
progresistas han estado diciendo esto
durante aproximadamente un ciclo paulo
freire por ejemplo diría que la
educación debe ser una experiencia de
emancipación por encima de todo o sea
para mejorar nuestras vidas y para
mejorar las vidas de otros
y allí nos enseñó que el aprendizaje no
se trata de una mera transmisión sino de
la construcción de conocimiento
también y de akerman es ese mapa pero
nos enseñaron que este proceso de
construcción ocurre mucho más
eficientemente cuando hace cuando se
construyen artefactos de externos se los
mejora y finalmente se los comparte con
otras personas pero todas estas teorías
tienen un gran problema depende de una
interacción significativa entre maestros
y estudiantes estas interacciones hacen
que el trabajo de los maestros sea muy
sofisticado pero el interesante que es
cuando hablo con empresas de tecnología
y gobiernos no lo normalmente la
respuesta es
que no hay manera de hacer este tipo de
educación económicamente viable entonces
pienso que la pregunta la pregunta es es
la cirugía cardíaca económicamente
viable
bueno la llama la mayoría de las cosas
importantes comienzan no no siendo
escalables y no siendo económicamente
viables como las cirugías de corazón la
democracia la democracia la atención
universal de salud todo esto
pero ahora volvemos a la pandemia un
poco
y lo que ha estado sucediendo en la
educación que queremos todos los
beneficios sin costo
queremos por ejemplo programación
robótica aprendizaje socio-emocional
habilidades del siglo 21 habilidades del
siglo 22 sin costo sin cambiar la lógica
de nuestros sistemas educativos es como
querer una cirugía cardíaca al costo de
una aspirina
y yo pienso es por eso que en esta
pandemia muchas personas simplemente
creyeron que la en la ilusión de que
podemos conectarnos en línea y que todo
estaba bien
y quien corrió en decirnos que todavía
están muy bien empresas de tecnología
educativa con sus aplicaciones
plataformas de ecosistemas ansiosas
clave por vender sus productos
y un mes después no estamos cuando nos
damos cuenta que el mundo utópico de las
compañías de stec de tecnologías
educativas con aprendizaje personalizado
sistemas de recomendación educación
impulsado de la inteligencia artificial
todas esas cosas simplemente no
funcionan
por lo tanto espero que estemos
aceptando un hecho simple la educación
como la atención médica es difícil y
costoso
lo que mejorará será un esfuerzo
coordinado el bien de señal
bueno esa es una genial pero cómo se
construye construyen típicamente los
sistemas educativos bueno históricamente
se ha partir de las necesidades sociales
pero que necesidades sociales teníamos
cuando comenzamos a construir lo que
tenemos hoy estamos a bueno alrededor
del siglo 15
con más comercio llegando a algunas
ciudades europeas como venecia se
necesitaban más personas para hacer
operaciones de aritméticas y así que
elaboraron planes de estudio para esto y
si miramos los libros texto como éste
de la época
se parecen mucho a los que tenemos hoy
mismo los problemas
que tuvieran eran muy similares como
esto
estos problemas muy similares a lo que
tenemos hoy
este es un problema real de
de los comerciantes de venecia
bueno estas cosas se parecen mucho con
que tenemos hoy no
es sorprendente pensar que gran parte de
lo que aprendemos hoy se originó en las
necesidades de comerciantes de venecia
de realizar cálculos rápidos y dividir
ganancias adecuadamente en un mundo sin
calculadoras pero hoy claro nuestras
necesidades sociales y tecnologías
disponibles son completamente diferentes
y yo creo que la pena me ha revelado lo
que estaba claro que el espíritu de
nuestro tiempo es que la juventud se
está despertando ante la urgencia de
cambio
tenemos por ejemplo
vemos a bojan es lado de los países
bajos que a los 17 años tuve la idea de
limpiar los océanos de plástico y
recaudó millones millones de dólares
o tal vez a los sobrevivientes de
tiroteos de parkland en los eeuu que
tomará la xunta de sus propias manos de
comenzaron a realizar actividades para
el control de armas sin esperar que los
políticos y adultos y adultos nos
decidan
o claro greta arn berg quien se
convirtió en una figura mundialmente
conocida que lucha contra el cambio
climático
a la edad de 16 16 años
los jóvenes no quieren esperar 20 años
no quiere por tanto necesitamos de una
pedagogía para la transformación para
ayudarlos
freire y para bert hablaban de escuelas
donde los estudiantes trabajan en
proyectos creen de factos aprendiendo
acerca de cosas impensables y
extraordinarias bueno por ejemplo en la
década de 660 sino el papel del xynthia
solomon se atrevieron a decir que los
niños deberían aprender la programación
de computadoras
los creyeron locos
costa rica para que siempre decidió
apostar en estas ideas y hoy sabemos que
fue una decisión muy acertada en la
actualidad
hoy existen miles de escuelas enseñan la
programación en todo el mundo
pero hoy podríamos tener otros temas
inimaginables como la genómica la
bioingeniería la inteligencia artificial
pero el problema es que esos temas
tardarán 30 años en ingresar a los
estándares nacionales porque ellos están
construidos parecer piezas inmutables
que es exactamente lo contrario lo que
lo necesitamos
pero hoy yo pienso en medio de la
pandemia la gente se preocupa como
asegurarse de que los niños y niñas
tengan acceso a la educación a esas
personas les diría algunas cosas la
primera es que no debemos tratar de
trasladar simplemente la escuela al
hogar sin cambios los hogares son
entornos muy diferentes y no podemos
esperar los mismos resultados entonces
yo pienso por qué no pensar en una
educación en casa que esté orientada a
los intereses proyectos e ideas
poderosas de los alumnos y también
investigación de temas inimaginables e
interesantes puede ser que una niña
tenga muchas plantas en casa y podría
ser un proyecto increíble investigando
las plantas o tal vez la química de la
cocina o el tal vez investigando las
injusticias del capitalismo
y tal vez al hacer este tipo de
experimentación educacional podríamos
darnos cuenta de que un niño que no era
considerado bueno en la escuela regular
podría ser muy competente en otro tipo
de aprendizaje
y no solo deseo que este experimento
funcione pero también inspira a las
escuelas después de la pandemia
espero que no regresemos usando más
videoconferencias simplemente espero que
regresemos haciendo unas preguntas
difíciles por ejemplo debemos cuestionar
el hecho que nuestra juventud sabe muy
poco acerca de cómo se propagan los
virus porque nuestros estándares
nacionales tienen tantos temas que no
hay tiempo en verdad para enseñar nada
en profundidad
tal vez las clases de ciencias y
matemáticas deberían deberían
concentrarse en este momento en el
cambio climático por ejemplo en las
pandemias y otros temas cruciales para
el día de hoy
pero en cambio estamos enseñando cómo
multiplicar fracciones
así yo pienso que lo que realmente
espero resulte de esta pandemia en la
educación es en primer lugar la
realización de que la visión de paulo
freire décimo el papel de una educación
para la emancipación para la
transformación y para cambiar el mundo
sea la que la que tenemos tendremos pero
esto también no no es todo también
quiero una educación que nos prepare
para un nuevo tiempo de vida un nuevo
tipo de mentalidad no no la mentalidad
de consumo una mentalidad de destrucción
ambiental de egoísmo de nuestra especie
de crecimiento económico ilimitado sino
una mentalidad que trata más de vivir de
manera sostenible reconociendo que no
estamos solos en este planeta pero
también celebrando la creatividad humana
y brindando a los niños y niñas
oportunidades para crear y resolver
problemas reales
bueno en 1478 los comerciantes de
venecia necesitaban una educación para
hacer cálculos aritméticos rápidos y la
construyeron en 2020 necesitamos una
educación para salvar nuestro planeta y
en nosotros mismos
construyamos lo
muchas gracias
[Música]